welcome back to a special edition of
Hannity joining us now to react to the
President's speech at CPAC the host of
the hit show justice judge Jeanine Pirro
is with us she's at CPAC 2018 all right
judge so you got to speak after the
president tonight but to the big dinner
which was so proud of you
and I look you you were there you saw
the speech the fact that Gallup is even
saying that optimism has changed
Rasmussen now has them at a magic number
of approval 50% results mattered to
people and I think results matter more
than noise that we've heard from the
last year you know what's amazing is the
energy in the room when the president
spoke was very uplifting it was
optimistic and it reflects the fact that
probably and as long as I can remember
we have a president who actually
fulfilled the promises he made during
the campaign the president was firm he
was funny he was personal and he was
resolute resolute and making sure that
American confidence is up that
underemployment unemployment is down and
that the American people understand that
they have the right to make a living
they have the right to be able to
provide for their families and they have
the right to secure and safe cities he
hit all the notes he hit it out of the
park and let me ask you Paul Sperry had
a great piece out today is a really
smart writer in the New York Post he's
talking about Devin Nunez in the
Intelligence Committee and the
intelligence community assessment and
what they're looking at is the ICA
including their footnotes to see if
there's any analysis in other words was
that like the FISA pre-cooked on the
unverified dossier in other words you
have the FBI the NSA the CIA were they
using an unverified dossier in this
capacity well I don't think there's any
question that they were I don't think
there's any question that they knew that
they paid for it that they that Hillary
Clinton and the DNC were involved in it
and then what happened was they did
everything they could to spread it among
the media and to use it in a court one
of the most the highest one of the most
private
Fortson in the country in a FISA Court I
mean here's my question though is a
specific yeah but if the Intel community
itself was using the unverified dossier
for there is a that's what I'm asking if
they use it provides it and for their
own intelligence gathering in other
words they're believing in their own lie
of course they're believing their own
line because if they didn't believe
their own lies Sean then they wouldn't
be able to perpetuate the narrative that
they are perpetuating Sean we're at a
point in American history where if we
don't make that sharp turn then were you
know headed for the tombs at this point
and that's why people elected Donald
Trump because the narrative and the lies
in the PlayBook has been unbelievable
I'm sorry to say this book I gave 30
years of my life in government I was a
believer and I am stunned at the lies
and at the criminality the corruption in
the conspiracy I I never thought I could
see this at our lifetime and especially
is it you know go into a FISA judge I
have to judge questions one is on the
issue of not telling the FISA Court
judge just a footnote that says it may
be political in nature when they knew it
was Hillary bought and paid for and what
do you make about the judge that also
was the judge in the senator Ted Stevens
case in Alaska
he's now general Flynn's judge and this
judge wants all exculpatory evidence and
he will decide what's exculpatory in the
in the Flynn place to be sent to him
that is seems to be highly unusual look
Sean I said it from the get-go the idea
of a FISA Court on this particular case
and there's something called
forum-shopping and that means and when I
was a judge we used to say oh we have a
will your name just comes up when it
comes up nonsense
alright and the fact that you got Ted
Stevens judge who's the same one who was
signing the FISA the the 90-day
extensions based on nothing other than
that that dossier and until and unless
you give me more evidence I'm going to
say it's based on nothing but a fake
dossier then what we've got is a problem
in the judiciary and I would have
expected a FISA judge to say everybody
cut
right here you are not to use the courts
for your political agenda it's unheard
of in American history and these judges
if they're not talking about one there's
corrupt as the prosecutor is this judge
looking to maybe throw this plea deal
out that Flynn made the idea that this
judge will decide what's a sculpt Ettore
and what is going to admit a not admit
is a continuation of the their narrative
I wouldn't trust them and what I would
do to be honest with you and look
generally I trust all judges but when
you've got a conflict you have an
obligation to recuse yourself you have
an obligation to say look I've got a
problem here let me give it to another
judge and I'm not saying that he is or
isn't bad but you know what when it
smells or when there's smoke there's
usually fire all right judge we
appreciate as always you being with us